[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and i will be
your
chauffeur on this journey
um tonight i have a pretty cool opening
that i want to talk to you guys about um
i was not so familiar with it until one
of my previous tournament games so i
decided to take a look after i played
this game uh see what this opening was
all about and see if it was something
worth looking deeper into turns out yes
it does otherwise we might not be here
um so i am talking about this game that
i played against show glasshouser i
think that's how his last name is
pronounced not 100 certain uh at the
bill wright st louis open open uh
earlier this month
and the opening i want to talk about
comes from a queen's gambit so i started
with d4 d5 c4
and then before the tournament uh a
little birdie told me that he played the
slav so i spent my time uh focusing on
on this opening but instead he surprised
me at the board with e6 no big deal i
didn't spend that much time prepping
anyways also yeah hello hello
welcome take a seat
um if you're just walking in i am
introducing the the lecture today we're
going over this weird variation in the
queen's gambit declined
so i was already out of my quote-unquote
prep of course i still know the position
i go knight c3 in this position
and now you're probably familiar with a
lot of moves here right you can go
knight f6 that's the main line queen's
gambit declines you know bishop e7
for some weird move order tricks you can
go c5 that's the terrash you can even
play c6 making the dreaded triangle
which is a favorite of many
but instead he chose this move a6
so i had never faced this in
over-the-board chess before
um and so this came as a surprise to me
so already over the board i am playing
on my own i don't know uh theory here
but fortunately in queen's gamut
positions things are generally going to
be pretty similar right you pretty much
have a good idea of where your pieces
belong and what you need to do
but as always it's very important to
slow down the second you don't know
exactly what move you're supposed to be
playing so after a6 i had to slow down
because i didn't know exactly what was
going on so what should you do whenever
you get surprised well you try to think
well what is my opponent one what was
the point of his move and how does that
affect what i want how does that affect
my plans so let's pause for a moment
here see if we can figure it out what is
a6 all about what's the point
what is the point looks kind of like a
ridiculous third move right
breaks all the rules
all the principles
also yeah hello to the youtube chat and
the twitch chat i see you there adi good
to see you in the chat
so surface level what does a6 do what
does having the pawn here accomplish
yeah covers b5 so why is that
potentially going to matter
um
i guess like
i guess black could
take on c and then defend
yeah that's exactly right this could
potentially be a problem for white
so one of the ideas as i've come to find
out after which i suspected in the game
is that uh black might be hoping to get
some sort of a good queen's gambit
accepted where after takes try to go
something like e3 you're not really able
to do this anymore because b5 is
actually going to land on the board and
i think this is like not a crazy line
for white in the queen's gamut accepted
you're allowed to play like this but
black is very much going to be keeping
the pawn here which is going to lead to
some really interesting positions and
maybe positions where white is actually
not not so comfortable
so
the surface level idea you know a6
defends b5 and black might want to play
d take c4 and b5 turns out that's that
very much might be the case here by the
way just to show you a fun little trap
if you thought you could pick up the
pawn like this
um who sees the problem
why doesn't this work for white
i actually wasn't familiar with this
until about 10 minutes ago because
slime seems kind of ridiculous for white
i don't think too many strong players
are going to go for it but
what's the problem
yeah the chat has it here i don't want
to spend too much time on this because
it's just a silly little trap the the
chat says b5 anyways and that's exactly
right
uh you might be thinking well what's
going on the a pawn is pinned why can't
i capture this
and black is not going to take you back
but instead will pin your knight to your
queen and then you're very very sad
because bishop takes b5 is unstoppable
and you lost the game in horrible
horrible fashion
so
i've been told that this is a trap but
good luck getting that in any of your
games i don't think that's really gonna
be too too prevalent
so with that in mind we have some idea
of why black might play this move b5 so
what can white do to sort of adjust our
game plan a little bit um to to deal
with those ideas
yeah we could go a4
so either you know we could go knight f3
and play a4 here anticipating b5 or
maybe even right away
what else is on the cards for us
yeah c takes d5 i think is by far the
the simplest way to play you just get
rid of this threat of d take c4 and
oftentimes white's actually not too
unhappy about taking on d5 here
relieving this tension uh in fact the
the main line that i play after knight
f6 is i do actually take on d5
so let's compare it to this main line in
this position i would be going bishop g5
e3
castles bishop d3 c6 or something queen
c2 maybe h6 for example
um or you know knight knight b to d7
uh all normal moves and you end up at
very normal queen's gambit decline
positions so this is sort of my
reference point this is what i'm used to
so in the game
after a6 i did just take on d5 now
there's nothing wrong actually with
playing knight f3 and a4 i think this
line is fine for white but it's sort of
giving black what he wants right you're
sort of playing into
this scheme where you're making a6 look
like a really useful move like
um
for example
in this position
um let's say
sorry let's say takes knight f3 black
might very well want to play a6 here to
induce a4
so
just some some move order stuff there
but you can kind of see how it makes a6
look like a useful move you have to give
that tempo back by playing a4
whereas if i just take on d5 now black
has to take back on d5 and i can kind of
say now this a6 move it's not going to
be so useful right you're not really
getting this b5 idea so uh what was the
point of you playing a6
so that being said the point is sort of
revealed just by the nature of it being
white's turn here
so as opposed to the normal line where
we saw this knight on f6 and i could
plant this bishop on g5 um sorry and i
could plant this bishop on g5 pinning
the knight to the queen in this case
bishop g5 obviously not quite as good
um so black's secondary idea with this
a6 move is it is just generally a useful
move to have it's nice to control the b5
square maybe we do want to play b5
someday
and it's also a useful waiting move
black is sort of biting his time waiting
for white to choose squares to put the
pieces on before he uh sort of reveals
his hand so he's delayed knight f6
preventing this normal move of bishop g5
he hasn't chosen a square for this
bishop yet depending on where we go he
might want to go to either e7 or d6 and
this is sort of why uh black has wanted
to play this a6 move sort of biting his
time
so with that being said uh
how should we try to develop we can't
play our normal move
bishop g5 at least not yet
so how do we keep going here
and the chat has a couple ideas which
we'll talk about
what do you think
i mean just like i don't know what first
but like knight f3 bishop f4
and then after that e3
yeah no that's exactly what i thought in
the game as well so
you can argue that putting the bishop on
f4 instead of g5 is a slight concession
maybe maybe your bishop would rather be
here pinning the knight than b on f4 now
in the game i didn't really believe in
that um i didn't think that that was
so much the case so i actually did play
bishop f4 immediately
now looking back i think white can put
on just a little bit more pressure by
playing knight f3 first here and the
reason why is going to become clear in
the game so i sort of didn't fully
respect this idea by black
but for example
you know i showed you the
triangle where
black played this move c6
and rather than c6 he chose a6 here and
black did this for a reason and the
reason is that black is actually going
to be attempting to play c7 to c5 in a
single turn thereby saving a tempo
rather than playing c6 followed by c5
right his argument is that a6 needs to
be included anyways
and he wants to save a tempo by going c6
to c5
now uh in the game that's exactly what
happens develop with bishop f4 goes
knight f6 go e3
c5 and i go knight f3 so he he got this
c5 idea through
now if i start with knight to f3 it
actually turns out it's not so easy for
black to get the c5 move you can't play
it immediately because i'll simply take
and your d pawn is falling
and if you try knight f6 as in the game
to prepare it now i won't put my bishop
on f4 but i'll put it on g5 instead and
in this case it does actually turn out
to be relevant because if you try c5 now
i can take and i have loosened your
control over this d5 pawn and once again
it's going to be kind of sad for you to
try to to get this pawn back i think
you're just not going to be able to hold
on to everything here at least not
comfortably you know for example
it takes here
um
okay i do think i can just take and
either queen takes or pawn takes and
i'll just take take on d5 winning a pawn
uh maybe i even have better here maybe i
can
get away with some stuff no i think i
should just take and take but okay
so that's the little move order subtlety
that i didn't figure out in the game
just played bishop f4 and let my
opponent get this c5 idea not going to
be the end of the world
i continue out with knight to f3 and
then black continues actually pushing in
the queen side with pawn to c4 so this
is a pretty interesting idea it's one
that hives that i've seen in slightly
different positions i've seen it against
my my f3 nimzo lines black sometimes
goes for this
but uh i had never seen it quite quite
like this
so once again we need to take a moment
our opponent has done something pretty
unusual and it's very much messing with
our standard plan right we want to put
our bishop on d3 and castle and black
has
definitely stopped that right he's
prevented our bishop from going to this
most natural
square on d3 and so we're going to have
to adapt our game plan for for sure
so
what else does this c4 move tell us and
what are we going to do about it
these are the questions that you kind of
have to ask yourself whenever you get
surprised in the opening right you have
to
really take it slowly take your time on
each turn and evaluate these these
dynamic positions the positions that
keep changing
yeah so it tells us that black is we
kind of have an idea of a plan right he
wants to go b5 sort of solidify over
here and maybe way down the road a5 b4
these kinds of moves get those pawns
rolling maybe you know he'll try to make
a c-pawn past with c3 at some point and
just kind of crush us on on the queen's
side
to try and get us on the queen side
so that's sort of what black is aiming
for
so the question is do we want to do
something about it on the queen's side
and the other question is
black is very much asking us a question
with this move the question is well what
are you going to do about your light
squared bishop you wanted to put it on
d3 you can't do that anymore i've taken
that away from you
and so those are the problems we sort of
have to
i mean not even necessarily solve right
away but be aware of and sort of
incorporate them in into our plan so we
got to look at this b5 plan and we got
to look at what to do with our bishop
that's that's what i'm thinking about in
this position
uh i'm also thinking about maybe what
this idea has sort of left behind in
black's position something else to look
at
yeah so this is definitely going to be a
really important idea is pushing e4
in the center
so there are actually sort of a couple
quote-unquote standard ways to
try and combat an early c5 c4 from black
or conversely an early c4 c5 from white
uh one of them is to break in the center
with e4 now why does this matter well of
course we are trying to loosen up
black's grip on the c4 pawn try to prove
that it's a little bit overextended by
getting rid of its defender on d5 now i
wasn't super happy with playing this
right away because i don't think we're
actually getting either pawn back um
it's kind of tough we'd like to play 95
here but black is going to be
comfortable just playing this move b5
and against a4 for example we'll go
bishop b7 defending the rook defending
our pawn on e4
and i'm not totally sure we're getting
away with it here with white definitely
an interesting line to consider
but it's not ready just yet
but breaking in the center is definitely
gonna be a really crucial idea for white
here
so
uh that with that in mind that sort of
led me to how i wanted to continue
developing
showed me how i wanted to continue
yeah what's the question
so that is the other sort of standard
way of targeting this pawn on c4 um
in fact that's normally just the way of
attacking pawn chains in general you can
attack the base of the pawn chain or you
can attack the head of the pawn chain so
b3 would be attacking the head of the
pawn chain
in this case i i didn't quite like it
because i've locked this bishop outside
of my pawn chain which is normally a
good thing keeps the bishop active but
in this case
i've moved my d-pawn i've moved my b
pawn my dark square bishop can't help
defend these dark squares and i thought
that moves like bishop to b4
and queen to a5
and knight to e4 and all of a sudden i
have big big problems defending my c3
square
so b3 is in general a normal idea here a
good idea here but uh specifically in
this instance we've weakened our dark
squares a little bit too much to get
away with it right away but you're
thinking along the right track you're
looking at the c4 pawn it looks weird to
you you're saying what can i do to try
to take advantage of it
but yeah b3 normally a good move in this
case a little bit too weakening
for example though
let me just put a ridiculous position on
the board let's say something like this
happened
um here i think b3 would be in a pretty
decent idea in fact maybe a very good
idea maybe you want to start with a4 and
then go b3
and the big difference here
is that you can just put this bishop
right on d2 and you never have any
problems with your knight and you are
immediately getting rid of this c pawn
so that's that's all the difference it
really takes is just having that control
over that square
okay little spoilers there for what i
played but no worries
so okay we have all these ideas floating
around now we know black wants to expand
on the queen's side we have this nice
idea of e4 but how do we turn that in
into direct moves right we have
long-term ideas of what's going on uh
but how do we turn that into moves how
do we develop our pieces how do we get
castled
what is the idea
yeah so we have to get our bishop active
somehow
so there are a couple ways you could do
this you could just move it to the only
square right now e2 and in fact this is
what was played in a very high level
game that actually went in in black's
favor but that's not to say this is a
bad move
but i was thinking how can we make this
bishop a part of our e4 plan
on e2 i would even argue it's sort of in
our way right we want to bring a rook to
the e file support our e pawn pushing
forward and on e2 our bishop just sort
of
sits in the way
so e2 definitely can't be the end
destination for the square now bishop b2
might be
you know a square on the path to
somewhere else but it can't be the end
destination
so long term
let's ask what diagonal do you think the
bishop belongs on
to help us support e4 especially
yeah the long diagonal so we want to go
somewhere on this diagonal now why is
that well because our bishop supports e4
and if we get e4 through then this
d-pawn is going to disappear and it's
going to be a monster bishop on this
long open diagonal attacking all the way
across the board hampering black on the
queen side where black might be trying
to expand right we're looking at moves
like b5 black wants to come get us
and that's going to make his life
difficult
so it turns out there's actually quite a
number of ways that you can get to this
long diagonal
this move bishop e2 not a bad move at
all um it was chosen by uh irwin lemi
and that game continued like this b5
castle bishop b7 knight e5 bishop e7 and
bishop f3 so this is a very reasonable
way to get to the diagonal that's what
erlin irwin lemie played but i actually
prefer the plan that i came up with in
in the game uh so not to say that bishop
b2 is bad i think it's totally fine um
very strong players stronger than myself
chose to play it in their games so
perfectly reasonable but notice that
bishop e2 wasn't you know the idea the
idea was to get this bishop to this
diagonal you always want to find squares
where pieces
can be useful
so with that in mind how else can we get
this bishop to the diagonal i see a lot
of people in the chat saying g3
but maybe there's there's an even better
way
uh the chat's circled back to b3 still
still not a good idea you still get get
uh
get into trouble on this diagonal
chad also mentioned this move queen to
c2 i think queen c2 is a very decent
move to include um but you can also
include this later we're not really
worried about bishop f5 i think and
especially after the la the move that i
chose bishop f5 becomes
actually pretty suspect
any ideas yeah
yeah so knight d2 i mean i think the
problem is you're just going to be a
little bit slow over here like black is
preemptively playing b5 he's not going
to wait around for you to to to get
around to playing um
this move b3 and then after that i think
you're still going to have problems on
this diagonal it might not be losing a
piece anymore but i'm i'm still going to
come for you with bishop b4
and i'm still going to come for you with
bishop or queen a5
and i'm still probably even going to
play this move uh night to e4 you know
maybe i'll take here first or something
maybe he'll throw this in
but you're still going to run into these
same problems
just because it's not you know
tactically winning
i don't think it needs to be for for
black here i think it just is going to
be
trouble for you overall so also
also this line you do have to keep track
of just b4 and c3 might even ruin your
day here as well um maybe not but but
maybe got to be careful about these
things
yeah so knight d2 is just sort of headed
in in the wrong direction so knight to
d2 does a great job of supporting e4 and
attacking c4 again
but let's say after b5 you do go for e4
you sort of run into
new new problems
in fact i think maybe i can improve and
play knight to c6 here and the problem
we run into is that
uh this was one step forward with
attacking e4 but it was sort of a step
backward by undefending d4 so now you do
have the uh the you know the support to
play this movie e4
but you don't have the support to keep
track of your d4 pawn after
so you got to be careful about you know
moving the same piece twice in the
opening you know it's just kind of a
basic principle that i'm sure you guys
are familiar with but
it's these specific problems like this
that tend to crop up when you when you
choose to to do these kinds of things
so knight to d2
sort of step in the wrong direction
h3g4 so this is pretty much the idea
that i played in the game however we can
do better than h3 and that's how i
arrived at the move knight e5 played in
the game so knight e5
defends the g4 square twice
and i want to launch this g pawn forward
throw it at my opponent and bring my
bishop to g2
so now how does this make any sense you
know um
how can you just get away with g4 in the
opening well uh especially when the
center ends up being closed right the
the tension in the center has completely
vanished our opponent's never taking on
d4 that means that these files are going
to stay closed for a little while longer
that's when you that's when you can get
away with sort of more aggressive pushes
on on the flanks
now if this pawn were on c5
let's say this happened
here i would be a lot more wary about
playing a move like g4 because my
opponent might try to open things up in
the center and my king might start
feeling the heat you know down down an
open e file for example
whereas with the pawn on c4 as in the
game um let's say this happens
you know my king is perfectly content to
sit here on e1 for a little bit and if
it's not i might even you know put it on
f2 i might still castle i'm not really
worried about the king's side because
the center again never going to open up
never really have to worry about this e
file
so 95 and g4 was was my idea
so in the game black chose to play b5
right away and i continued out with a3
first sorry to stop any b4 ideas bishop
b4 ideas just a useful move
bishop to b7 was black's choice sort of
anticipating pressure on this diagonal
and then i do continue with g4 turns out
the computer thinks g3 is is also
totally fine i wasn't quite as happy you
always have to be quite uh you know
you know scared about leaving your
bishop with no retreating moves
especially on like the fourth rank
very easy to just suddenly end up
trapped like imagine knight e4 comes
with tempo one day
i don't do anything and then all of a
sudden like um okay this might be
you know just g5 i think this is
actually still winning a piece right you
can very quickly
lose this bishop if you leave it with no
retreating squares so i was happier with
g4 it gives my bishop this flight square
and allows me to potentially even go
crazy on the king's side just start
pushing over here the center's closed i
don't need to worry about my king quite
so
immediately and so i can take a little
space and i can very naturally develop
my bishop out to g2
so so here we go
now my opponent continues with knight to
e4 sort of anticipating that this piece
might get kicked around with g5
and i could capture here but again i
started to worry a little bit about um
let's say bishop g2 started to worry a
little bit about my my dark squares over
here wasn't so happy letting this knight
go
so i came out with bishop to g2 first
um this queen came out to a5 and this is
actually a pretty big mistake by black
already
so the the engine is not so happy with
my choice in the game i think it was a
very practical choice looking at some of
the lines but it turns out white is very
much better here uh
a lot better in fact after queen to a5
so i'm curious if you guys can can come
up with the options that give black the
advantage i definitely considered them
but it was uh
it was a little bit scary
there's a question why didn't black play
h5 doesn't that stop your idea well 95
is is a good move sort of regardless you
know we we aren't
super committed to playing g4 and h5 is
going to make some serious weaknesses
for black so let's say 95 h5 you can go
bishop e2 for example sort of targeting
that guy
and
i'm not sure it stops me altogether
either i might might still go h5 or g4
someday
i might just bring the bishop out to f3
sort of going back back to plan b
so some great ideas in the chat which
i'll i'll get to in a moment but i want
to give you guys another couple
another minute or two here to
take in what's going on
ah and a very bad idea from the chat
which i was hoping to see as well
one of your ideas chat loses tactically
so be careful be careful
okay now i see b4 b4 also loses
tactically too the very tricky on hassan
but aside from that another move is is
tough
okay let's throw out some ideas
obviously
black is trying to get us right
so what do you want to do about it we
can defend our knight
we can get rid of the knight on e4 or we
can ignore it and do something else so
what do those options look like in
actual chess moves
yeah so bishop takes knight getting rid
of the knight getting rid of the threat
what else can we try
what's the quote-unquote simple move
just to
you know pass the turn back to the
opponent say you made your threat i
dealt with it your turn
always good to have a simple move in
your back pocket that you don't have to
worry about you just know okay this is
fine
aha so this was the idea by the chat
that i think loses tactically and the
chat also came up with rook c1 which i
think might also be
bad but i am less certain of that so
queen to c2 um you always have to be
aware of some pretty common tactics
in these kinds of openings where your
rook on a1 ends up a little bit stranded
so here i'm not sure the absolute best
way to go about it i feel like i should
just capture first
and
now if
actually maybe i shouldn't capture first
let's say pawn takes then i can actually
come out with b4
and you're pinned along this file
if you take i take
and big trouble big big trouble
now that being said maybe you can get
away with queen takes here but i still
think b4 is going to kind of ruin your
day you have to go somewhere
and
now
pro probably just takes if you try queen
d2 you can go c3 first
and either takes or b3 so something
along these lines is gonna be tough for
a
tougher white to deal with i think
actually probably i take on c3 what am i
talking about
looks very very scary right black is
getting sort of what he wants he's
getting this past pawn on the queen side
so queen to c2 pretty scary idea um rook
to c1 might also run into some trouble i
can take and no matter how you take back
i'm potentially thinking about capturing
on a3 your rook is pinned so you can't
take back can't take back like this
because your rook hangs
so
what is the simple move that's left to
deal with the threat you've got one more
option
what was that
okay so bishop takes night getting rid
of the the knight but i'm not so happy
giving up the bishop so there is a way
just to defend the knight and not allow
these tactics
so
yeah queen to c1 solves all the problems
defends this way defends this way
defends this way that's the simple move
so in the game i did actually choose
this quote-unquote simple move now the
computer does actually quite like this
move bishop takes e4 um however i
thought that this was pretty far from
simple
so
uh you always want to be wary giving up
a bishop for a night like this
especially in this kind of
i would say tactical position where sort
of everything's in flux
i also was not so happy about this
knight on e5
if i try castling for example
my knight is trapped trapped in the
center of the board
um i didn't think advancing this pawn
uh to e4 was going to be quite right for
me until
i was ready to deal with it pretty
immediately until i was more developed
castled and could
start attacking it immediately but the
computer says no worries you just go g5
um then i think b4 was suggested at some
point maybe bishop b7 first he's like
yeah no worries you just go get him h4
and then it just keeps going it just
like it keeps going after
after everything it's like yeah all of
this easy easy peasy
and i think it gets like here or
something and it's like yeah white's
white's crushing it no no worries at all
so that sort of hint of an idea that i
had with g4 potentially going for a pawn
storm peter's like yeah you should have
just done it just go and get them you'll
do great uh however i thought that this
way of playing would be a little bit
risky uh why is that well again without
this light squared bishop i was worried
that one day this bishop might come back
to haunt me you know i am always nervous
about giving up uh the bishop pair
um
so
i wasn't so happy with bishop e4
now the last idea is ignore it you can
ignore the threat you say your threat's
not strong enough and you just play a
useful move in this case that would be
castling and it turns out the computer
also very much likes this way of playing
although again not so easy to do
practically over the board when you're
just sort of playing by your own hand so
it says knight c3 pawn c3 queen c3
and then it just doesn't care it says
yeah you go rookie one and very
concretely
the computer goes e4
takes an e4 takes on e4 and the it says
black simply doesn't have enough time to
to save the king
so just as an example line let's let's
see what's going to happen
um yeah let's say
hold on here
uh okay it wants to go f6 first fair
enough it wants to kick the knight and
then take
and now let's say rookie one so let's
say black tries to develop it's actually
just going to go e4
take e4 rookie 3 hitting the queen the
queen goes back it goes d5
blocking off this bishop you try to
castle it goes knight d4
jumping in to all the squares
and it just says positionally black
black is just destroyed here you go uh
bishop c5 bishop b4 queen b6
and i'm sort of forgetting i think you
just go 96 here and the white pieces are
just totally invading if you take a take
and i think i might take your rook i
might also not take your rook i might
just go and try to checkmate you
but either way it's like yeah easy peasy
white's crushing here i think it's some
big number
uh only
only plus one
um so
white a lot better but uh still kind of
scary to play like this right i'm giving
up my pawn i'm sort of
making everything a lot clearer for
black right i'm saying yeah you can have
my pawn i'm just going to rip open the
center and come after you
so i wasn't so happy with either of
these options which is why i chose the
simple move queen to c1 now computer
says it's wrong i think practically very
reasonable move to play you know my
position has a lot of trumps my pieces
all make sense i have a lot of pressure
in the center might as well just sit on
the position keep the game going
um black now does play f6 forcing my
knight back so i go back to f3
and now knight to c6 getting developed
uh this move doesn't really make a
threat so i have no reason not to
continue with normal play so i just go
ahead and castle
and then my opponents uh sort of stuns
me i think no not yet not yet uh now
after castles i am actually threatening
to capture this night because i'm much
happier about trading the night for the
night when i can leave my bishop here
with pressure like let's say
uh bishop ease okay sorry i'm
threatening this as well so tough to
play reasonable move let's say rook d8 i
very much am going to capture this go
knight d2 and now you're in a lot of
trouble i think you just lose this pawn
by force so
black facing this kind of this kind of
pressure takes on c3
of course i want queens on the board
here it's my opponent's queen starting
to look a little silly on a5 right it
can't influence this side of the board
at all and my queen gonna make a lot
more sense if e4 gets played know i'm
jumping into the jumping into the game
uh and then my opponent shocks me plays
queen side castles so my instinct over
the board was that this move didn't make
any sense and it turns out that this
move doesn't make any sense um so
why why doesn't this move make sense
what's what's going on here what's the
big deal
so the king is pretty exposed right but
the the main thing is sort of a little
bit deeper than that think back to what
we were talking about about the c4b5
structure overall what did black want
with this structure
he wanted something
turns out this is very anti-positional
move
yeah black has more space on the queen's
side and i was saying this a5b4 this is
what black wants to do he wants to push
on the queen side he wants to go win on
this side of the board
now it's very difficult to justify
playing a5 b4 with your king on c8
and that's why black simply couldn't do
this
i think his thinking was that i've
committed to this g4 move maybe that
weakens my king and he'll be able to
come after me on the king's side
but
the king side is sort of where where
white's gonna be a bit stronger right
you have all these pieces over here on
the queen side ready to sort of support
this advance like let's say you give
black a couple free moves here
and now i know i'm being very generous
to black but let's say you know
i'm generous to black
one more move b4 you know let's say all
this actually happens
i think white is is just busted here
like oh you know all the pieces for
black support the the queen side this
bishop supports the center supports the
rook on e8 this is what black wants to
do he wants to push over on this side of
the board come and get us
um this is the plan like this is just
this is just the plan here for black
so with king or with queen side castles
you deny yourself your main plan
basically now i think black was already
in a little bit of trouble before this
but after this his position just sort of
falls apart there's just nothing that
black is really playing for
and the rest of the game black is either
responding to white's threats or trying
to play catch up and you know make some
sort of crazy attack work on the king's
side uh neither of which were were
destined to to get anywhere
so that being said we all agree
queenside castle is no good king's
exposed it denies black his main plan
um but what are we gonna do about it
right what are we gonna do about it
that is exactly right so
what what did we want to do early on of
course like you said we wanted to play
e4
and so we can just continue with this
plan so how do we do that
okay yeah queen to c2 is one option or
as brian said knight to d2 um and here
it's going to make a lot more sense than
the first time we were talking about it
now why is that first time we were
talking about it we were worried about
the defense of our d4 pawn here
obviously our d-pawn is very well
supported now that we have a pawn on c3
and black is not challenging it with the
pawn on c5 so knight d2 actually the
best move in the position you just
support c2 now i think queen c2 probably
a very good move as well i don't see any
reason why this move should be should be
wrong
um
if anything i think 92 might be a little
bit better because it also has the added
bonus of just allowing this bishop to
see a little bit more but yeah queen c2
another great move another great move
rookie one really any idea that supports
e4 here i think is is very strong
now what i did is very slightly worse
than all those moves i said well why
wait around just did it
which is also also fine here white is a
lot better still
so what was the point of it all well if
you take now i do want to go knight to
d2 and the point is i've attacked you
twice you don't have time to recap to
defend it twice you know you can only
defend it once on the next turn so white
gets the pawn back no matter what
uh and this is what i expected to happen
in the game i thought maybe black would
try to reposition with knight to e7 come
in with knight e4
um he would get knight d5 and you know
he's got a little bit of counter play
here he's on my on my c pawn thought i
might just come back with bishop to g3
and we would play some position like
this this is the position i got to sort
of in my head
now let's say black plays
uh
a slow move here hard to suggest a slow
move let's say bishop b7 what does white
want to do here what's next we got what
we wanted in the center we opened it up
what's next on the agenda
yeah okay
all right so you want to come in like to
knight c5 yeah
yeah knight c5 might be a very decent
move um but what i was thinking is our
bishops look great they're raking down
the board our knight also very useful in
the center here you know i think maybe
even more useful in c4 or on e4 than on
c5 uh it is an offensive piece
threatening to go to these squares and
it's also a nice defensive piece it
keeps track of her little c pawn back
here who might need some help
so i wanted to focus on these pieces
next
so how can we get these pieces in the
game
yep rookie one great move
probably one of the best moves
and one more idea that really sticks out
i'm looking at this guy i'm looking at
him yeah a4 um
probably
just as good as rookie one i mean these
are both moves you really really want
rookie one only open file and important
to stop the king from running back to
the side of the board it should already
be on
um but a4 is how you really get atom
right you you break down this structure
in front of the king you say how dare
you castle on the side where you pushed
all your pawns that gives me lots of
targets to open up files so a4 and i
thought the black would have been pretty
lost in this position turns out it's
it's true
so i sort of suspect my opponent
was thinking about these same things and
was looking for some way to make it
complicated so here he actually did not
take on e4 instead he chose this move g5
hitting my bishop um i said okay you got
me i'll move my bishop out of the way
and then he just comes through with h5
now i mean it's a nice little idea
trying to like uh just ignore me in the
center and come after me on the king's
side but it just turns out to not really
do enough
so white to move here and
it's it's pretty crushing and it turns
out it's pretty crushing for the ideas
we were just looking at so how do we
make it work how do we combine these
ideas
and i just realized i didn't really
explain a4 um but you'll get to see it
later in the game so you'll see why
just want to open up that a file
oh god james uh james just suggested my
least favorite move in the position oh
no
i'll talk about it in a moment as well
yeah e takes d uh works tactically and
it's desirable so that's the two things
you kind of have to ask in these
tactical positions um can i do this do
is do i like lose material and then do i
want to do this and sometimes people
forget to ask that second question but
it turns out yes you do want to play e
takes d5 here um now the question of can
you well you have to check
um this traps your bishop do you care
you have to take here
black takes back
and then you know let's say i can even
do something sort of funny like bishop
to e5 and
don't think you're so happy
about this exchange of pieces right i
have one upon your g5 pawn is weak
you've opened no files in front of my
king and my knight is a monster so
can you do it yes we can
do we want to do it yes we do why do we
want to do it well it resolves
this problem here where we thought black
might take our e pawn and it serves the
same purpose we're opening up this
diagonal we're getting at the black king
so ed5 great move our opponent has to
play 97 for the reasons i was just
showing
and
now
we do actually have to respond our
opponent is making a threat
uh what do we what are we gonna do about
so
oh i also forgot to talk about james's
move james suggested e5 which makes me
sort of wince so h4 i think just wins
tactically wins the bishop but e5 you
know while you you know you might think
that it's really good to go after this
g5 pawn it's very much the wrong
direction you want to open these things
up you want to open up these lines
towards the enemy king and this helps
lock them down right black is happy if
he keeps this d5 pawn
um so e5 definitely the wrong way to go
so
we're here
so h4 very bold um i don't think
tactically
this one is is gonna work out so we can
take here
knight's attacked and we take here
and we have regrets
um h3 instead yes so that is one of the
two main options here h3 is one option
and we have one more big option to
consider
okay d6 trying to keep the tactics
flowing could be good
um
yeah i think maybe d6 black's just going
to play knight d5 and
we have the same problems and i think
maybe
black is recapturing a little bit more
comfortably even
might be helping them out
gh5 yeah so so the two options here so
again you know you try to organize your
thoughts you say okay i see my
opponent's threat um it's a very
complicated position but if you can
organize like this you say okay i see
what he's trying to do how can i respond
to it i can play h3 play g takes h then
you spend some time you say which one is
better well if i play h3 he opens up the
file and it's his turn again maybe he
starts playing knight d5 he comes into
f4
and it looked a little dicey to me
whereas if i play gh5
i'm very happy if he spends uh his turn
playing rook h5 now i get the turn i get
to do what i want to do i'm done
responding to him
and i can continue with what ideas that
we were talking about what did we want
here in similar positions
yeah rookie one and a four right you
know it's it's our turn now we get to be
sort of the ones uh
pushing forward with our plan and that
is a great way to look at these opposite
side castles positions it's like you
know you want to play with urgency you
want to be the one advancing your plants
you want to be the one that gets there
first so to speak
so i chose g takes h5 in the game turns
out it's it's correct
um my opponent went for bishop takes d5
who sees the problem with knight d5
really quickly
of course always check
sometimes the king has no squares
um
and this knight was needed to guard a
square otherwise uh you can't play f5
here and you just lose material and it's
material that i don't even have to take
right away it can be like extra mean
play rookie one or something
try to come after you
um so that loses which is why bishop d5
gets played
and now of course just a4 we get our
turn we can play what we want a4 i'm
going to open that a file get at the
king
queen b6 is played of course no reason
not to play a b
and now i've got the open a file
and i've got this bishop and this
diagonal's open as well something for my
opponent to think about
and my opponent is completely busted
right his attack is way slower he has
his queen's nowhere near the attack he
still has to take my h-pawn
it's tough for him to make new threats
so it turns out white is completely
winning here if only i find the right
idea
so so what can we do
so hello to sam's
in the chats
he's accusing me of being pre-recorded i
would never
i would never pre-record myself
defending it being live
so at first glance
not so easy right it's bishop defends a8
this queen defends these squares
and it's true i've got this nice looking
bishop right this nice unopposed bishop
for now but how do we actually make it
all work how do we actually invade here
and get after the enemy king
for a moment
it looks like everything's defended so
bishop h3 i think here part of the idea
of this move bishop d5 rather than
knight d5
is that uh
maybe black wanted to play bishop e6 in
reply if you go
actually maybe g5 or f5 in reply is is
also good
it's a little bit scary with knight to
g5 okay let's stick with bishop b6 and
you might get this check
king will come up
and i can take
but all of a sudden the king made it
back to where he belongs he's back over
on the king's side which is still where
the king belongs despite queen side
castles
so bishop h3 wasn't wasn't my favorite
so also yeah just just some weirdness
with maybe even g4
followed by f5 actually this is probably
this is probably the problem um somehow
there's there's a counter tactic here
where all your pieces are hanging
so not quite bishop h3
also yeah maybe king b7 is playable
there as well uh nikara but that g4
tactic looks kind of nasty
yeah that's exactly right and it's
pretty much dealer's choice however you
want to do it
so the one thing you shouldn't do is
step to a3 just because it gives
to too many
you know too much counter play you don't
want to put your piece on that square
um
but that leads to the question well all
these squares are defended so how do you
do it well pretty much any way you want
using the a2 square rook a2 totally wins
queen b1 heading to a2 totally wins
um
c2 d2 b2 i think are all also fine all
with the idea you want to play queen a2
or you want to play rook a2 quinn a1 and
these moves are just very very strong so
maybe i can give an example line
say rook a2
maybe queen c6
attacking along this diagonal the
computer is very brave just says queen
a1 you don't even need that piece you
just go rook a7 and checkmate the guy
right away knight d5 for example
bam bing bang boom
meet my friends chris and cross and
that's it for your king
okay
so it's just like rook a2 is is nothing
and i like tried to find some like lines
that like made a difference it just
never makes a difference
you just always get checkmated with
these ideas or k6 as well it's it's just
just over for black on on the a file
now i was noticing this idea of queen to
c6 and i wasn't so bold as the computer
to just ignore it and let black take my
piece so i played this move knight d2 a
big mistake allowing black to to take
here first and alleviate just a little
bit of the pressure
um that being said
you know should have just been a hero
gun rook a2 queen a1 would have been
totally winning um
so good find good finds now my opponent
plays f5
with a pretty normal looking idea let's
go f4 lock out my bishop
once again the computer calls me a
coward it's like yeah just play rook a5
queen a1 and go checkmate the guy what
are you doing this bishop you didn't
need this bishop let him take your
bishop doesn't matter doesn't matter
rook a7
um look at this checkmate you're just
he's he's busted i think maybe even
you're supposed to
are you supposed to go to k7 i don't
even remember
um okay the computer says knight f5 here
and then yeah something like 94 and you
just
i don't know the computer's crazy
now
i i was like all right i don't want to
be a hero i want to keep my pieces so i
want bishop e5 again
perfectly fine for white white's a lot
better uh but now black takes on h5
and finally i get around to playing my
idea i'm like okay i dealt with all the
threats let's go rook a7
uh very human way to approach it i think
my opponent goes knight d5 and then
here's my last chance here i really
should be a hero because my next move
does give away um almost the entire
advantage uh believe it or not
so and this one i very very nearly did
convince myself to do so knight to d5
what does this move accomplish well it
stops my threat i rook to c7 it
threatens knight to e3
that's what's going on here
so i said well you know what's a good
move for me anyways just want to play
rookie one
cut the king off a little bit and then
i'll you know
go about my business trying trying to
checkmate him um it turns out now is
still the time to just be a hero you
don't need any of these pieces over here
he's just so busted
on the king's side that after queen to
a5 it's just like there's nothing you
can do you can try bishop d6 i just
check you
i take your rook on d8 you're dead
um
yeah just
check me just check me like right away
or i take your queen so you know easy
enough
um if you try something else
other than
i mean i don't know what else you can
try to be honest
yeah you just go queen at one and it's
just dead you know
rook a6 here queen a5 suck
very scary stuff
okay i don't know what this line is this
is what the computer thinks the best
line is which includes this move h3
so like yeah
yeah you can calculate all this and win
but very tough very tough for a human
that being said definitely should have
done it rookie won and things get very
tough for me
so of course black should just play rook
to d7 it's time to play a little defense
and
it turns out i don't have much at all
here if i go like queen a1
takes takes
uh and it it turns out to be very tough
for white to make any progress here like
queen to b7 kind of running out of
pieces to to attack with again it can
get pretty difficult
so that was my opponent's one and only
chance but instead um you know it's a
complicated position where he's low on
time he tried to come after me tried to
play knight f4 counter-attacking
but of course i just take this
and now finally finally finally i
mustered up the courage to play queen a1
and things just fall apart for for black
here he's way way way too slow this rook
stops the king from escaping these two
major pieces are going to get it done
with the king on c8 if you try like
attacking me for example just show a
simple line
oh no i'm so scared queen g2 except not
really
it's just going to be
sort of checkmate right away
i can corral your king no escaping
through the e file
um so my opponent decided to lose his
mind um i thought that he would try
bishop to d6 trying to defend with
bishop to uh to b8 but this one is
actually not so hard to deal with i can
give this check rook a6
more checks queen a5 even
and
we just we we sort of just encircle the
king here like queen c6 runs into rookie
7 for example with takes when i pick up
the queen and black is it's just falling
apart just falling apart here
uh instead he really really really lost
his mind played uh bishop a3 which is
just some some nonsense he was like all
right i'm stopping rook 8 at all costs
and he thought that he had checkmate
here after rook h2
queen h6
rook g8
and of course which square do you go to
you all saw it coming from a mile away
which square do you go to
last problem to solve
of course you have to go to f1 so
someone was actually spectating my game
at this point and they like lost their
minds they walked away they're like oh
man i thought you just made it in two
not made it into you are mated in two if
you go to f2 you don't get to the e2
square
king is boxed
rook g1 is checkmate scary stuff
but i can just go here
and now after check or check
i go to e2
rookie eight doesn't help you i can play
any of these three moves which i'll win
the game i just chose king d1
takes takes and you're never
never getting a perpetual here you can
check
check
and the knight does a very good job of
defending the king
and black is busted so show went ahead
and resigned here after a really fun
game really interesting game
so
uh with that being said i think i'm a
little bit over time already but any
final questions for me about this game
anything at all
so what was that
yeah no it was a really fun game i think
it was probably one of my better games
of the tournament and i had a lot of fun
playing it
uh just a quick recap of what went on we
spent a lot of time in the opening after
a6 and this is something i've been
stressing a lot lately whenever you get
surprised in the opening you need to
play you know you can't just rely on
playing normal moves you have to think
about what's going on how the position
keeps changing and that's what we did in
the lecture here we looked at every
single move we looked at what was going
on how does this change our plans
and eventually when our opponent made a
critical mistake castling queen side we
knew how to take advantage of it we
relied on our normal plans we opened
things up we got to the black king and
we were successful in the end despite
messing up some of the tactics along the
way which is always going to happen
so thank you all very much for joining
me if you have some time please stick
around wonderful grandmaster in
residence romaine eduard is going to be
coming up right after me here and he'll
be talking about some some more chess
some more chess as always my name is
caleb denby thank you very much for
watching and i will see you next time
[Music]
you